[Music]
lots of breaking news regarding
president joe biden i must warn you some
of this information may be
shocking if you have any children in the
room you may want them to leave i'll
give you three seconds
okay we've just learned from our
hard-working colleagues at cnn that
president biden has expressed a
preference
for building a fire in the oval office
and sometimes
he adds a log to keep it going let's go
live on the ground to one of our
reporters
thanks greg i'm outside walking holding
a notepad
and it's true president biden has
expressed a preference for a fire built
in the oval office
and sometimes he'll add a log to keep it
going
according to my sources this is quite a
departure
from the previous tenant at the white
house whose only fires he stoked
were that of hatred and bigotry of
course that came from an anonymous
source who might also
be me back to you greg so once again
this information
coming from cnn likely through an
anonymous source but we have no reason
to question it
president biden expressing preference
for a fire built in the oval office and
even adding a log to keep it going
let's bring one of our experts on this
greg what do you make of this
thanks greg as a historian i must say
from a historical perspective
this is quite astounding george
washington chopped down a cherry tree
but he wasn't resourceful enough to use
it as
fuel unlike president joe biden again as
a historian i don't think it's premature
to say
we are witnessing not the greatest
president we've ever seen
but the greatest president we will ever
see
sorry greg we're getting more breaking
news from cnn it appears on his first
air force one flight this month
president biden spent that time
reading the newspaper cnn describes him
as quote a wary passenger on a commuter
shuttle
let's go back to our expert for a quick
reaction
as a prominent historian i can see that
president biden's method of relaxation
calls to mind the great leaders of our
time
gandhi martin luther king and perhaps
even jesus christ
what a role model for children whose
parents have private jets
it's so important to read when you can
even at 35 000 feet
greg even at 35 000 feet
a lot going on on this very busy day at
the capitol the ap
also reporting the president beat one of
his granddaughters at a video game known
as mario
mario kart i'm sorry i've been told we
don't condone men beating women at
anything
and i'll be taking a leave of absence to
profoundly educate myself on this matter
i always wanted to interview myself very
good
yes thank you dana this is some hard
hitting stuff from cnn
man i mean it must be fun to be a
democratic
pr person or maybe it's boring
because it's like so easy
actually i think every president has a
fire in the oval office
i'm pretty sure um they better
enjoy it while they can though i think
that the rubber is going to hit the road
pretty soon because once they get this
coveted relief bill done
i think that the progress this sort of
understanding and the truth between the
progressives and the moderate uh
democrats is going to come crashing to
an end kennedy
i still don't know whether he has
whipped cream on his hot chocolate
i need to know this and marshmallows
greg
i hope the administration takes a firm
stand here because those are the
important topics
yes i'm watching this i'm thinking it
reminds me of going to nagano japan
in the mountains and seeing the little
snow monkeys who are adorable and
everyone
everyone walks around going oh my gosh
these monkeys are adorable but you know
what they do they throw snowballs and
then steal your stuff
imagine the kind of damage an adorable
president can do
when the press isn't watching when
they're so busy fawning
and giving every detail every nuance of
his adorable life
uh he's gonna be pilfering and and
robbing the country blind and
i'm sorry to say greg as a realist we're
all host yeah we are
juan uh this has to be the easiest white
house
beat in history
well actually you know i'm glad you put
it that way greg because historically
uh this is what happens when you get a
new president that they start talking
about does he like
nestle's hot chocolate or ovaltine at
night what are his favorite books
what about the dogs this is the way that
the press does it now of course
if the cycle the historical cycle holds
then of course the next step
is they bring out the baseball bats and
they begin walloping him
but i think that what we're doing here
is we're talking about well gee they
didn't do this so much with president
trump
but you got to remember the first time
out the box trump was lying about the
size of the inaugural crowd then he had
the ban
on people of muslim faith coming into
the country so i think a lot of things
just got skipped
it just well i think the ban is a fact i
don't know how you argue that
well but anyway they just they just it
just got skipped and then
of course the lots of anger and and the
media going after him
i think that one of the things that
biden is selling
is normalcy that things can be normal
again and right now the american people
and the press are buying it
the variable in the bad countries wasn't
muslim because there were muslim
countries that weren't banned
uh want uh jesse um
are you excited about the town hall
tonight on another network will you be
watching it
no i won't i'm gonna be watching the
bachelor rerun because i missed it last
night
um listen we just got off four years of
a roller coaster
and now we're riding the tea cups and
the press is trying to sell this as
somehow
sexy the inane details of joe biden's
personal lifestyle i'm sorry i don't
care how many logs he puts on the fire
or what time he goes to bed we just had
like
entertainment tonight in the white house
guys getting sued by porn
stars ordering mcdonald's attacking
people on twitter past
midnight are you kidding me like you
can't now go to this and say yeah
he beats his granddaughter at mario kart
and expect us to read this
the real action though the family
scandal and the radical policy
you have a president whose son and
brother are under investigation
for chinese money laundering and tax
fraud you're
sending billions of dollars to corrupt
teachers unions who have a history of
embezzlement
he's just spiking the the cuomo nursing
home
investigation that's where the action is
not the bed time and the logs
that is exactly kennedy's point
kennedy's
it's like is that he is getting away
with stuff because he's
just so you know and and to watch point
to your point trump was so over the top
he couldn't get away with anything
because they were watching his every
single move because every one of his
moves was interesting
and over the top so they watched him
whereas with
biden it's just you know hot chocolate
and fuzzy slippers
all right